the things that I thought served me in
my 20s weren't self-authored the things
that I thought I wanted and the things
that I wanted to want had diverged I
didn't want the things that I wanted so
I noticed around about 26 27 that all of
the training strategies that I'd been
relying on like Push Pull legs and bro
split looked fantastic but kind of got
out of breath going up a set of stairs
and I couldn't bend over and touch my
toes so what I realized was I I probably
should try and pivot my training and I
saw it with a lot of my friends the
training protocol that you followed
through your 20s you get toward the end
of your 20s and I'm like I'm kind of
done with this and then people pivot and
they start doing yoga or they do
Brazilian jiu-jitsu or they do
kickboxing but it was actually the lead
measure of a whole bunch of other
changes that thing of I didn't want what
I wanted is dopamine the chase was your
reward so when you go shopping and you
buy whatever the trinket is that you
thought you wanted and then you get it
into bit blah how many times do you have
to do that before you realize okay
trinkets aren't for me there's nothing
in trinkets the ambition should be
emotions